all right gwen
gwen welcome back hi so so last time we
spoke you were fresh
you're a brand new porn actress yes i
was
i had done maybe two scenes last time we
spoke just like a few weeks into the
business yeah
now you're a seasoned veteran yes i'm
like a year like a year and three weeks
has it been a year
wow um so how are how have things
changed oh
um well i'm definitely more
i think i grew into myself over the year
a lot like
way quicker than i would have if i was
not in porn
and um i'm just a much more confident
more open person now how old are you
again i'm 22. you're 22.
and you know this this career is not for
everyone
no certainly but you you told me last
time i think that you were kind of
very curious and and this very sexual
and this this kind of works for you
yeah i am um i'm a learner
i love to learn new things and i love to
try new things
you know i'm i cannot take people's word
for anything i have to go and find it
out for myself
so that in combination with being a
pretty open
and experimental person sexually porn
seemed like the perfect idea
and it to me it really was i really
found something i enjoy
and it's not for everyone but i think if
you have a tough skin
and you enjoy having sex you should try
it definitely
and and how so do you have friends here
you've made friends
i have i've made friends and the people
you meet that are outside the business
do you tell them or i do i tell people
that i do porn i usually
don't say like i do porn i'm whenever
people ask what i do
i tell them i do adult modeling and
they're like oh okay so you do porn
yeah and i'm lucky enough that the
people i've met
don't mind and do your does your family
know about it
yeah my family knows about it how'd they
take that
um they were pretty accepting of it like
my both my parents my mom and my dad
were like you know
it's not really what we would want you
to be doing
but i've always been someone who just
does what i want anyways no matter what
anyone thinks
and my parents know that so they were
supportive of the
decision they were like you know you're
making your own choices and we're proud
of you for that
that's pretty progressive for kansas
yeah and family right
yeah it is pretty progressive i guess
for kansas
and you feel safe you're not you're not
being exposed to anything dangerous or
anything like that
no i i feel safe um
[Music]
one thing about porn is like it's very
important that
everyone's comfortable they make that
pretty clear
from day one like you can't
you shouldn't and you won't do anything
you don't want to do
and every time i'm on set every time i
meet
a new person in the industry like i'm
always comfortable way more comfortable
than i've been with strangers
really so it's it's a good place to be
what is your experience with the
professionalism and
the other co-workers are is everyone
respectful and easy to work with or do
you get some weird
situations sometimes for the most part
everyone's very professional
at least the people i've worked with the
majority of them have been
people who have been in the industry for
a few years
so they're experienced and they know
what they want from the industry so they
do their best to be a professional
respectful
and kind person if there ever
is like someone who's not super
professional or like super nice they're
usually
like brand new a little bit younger and
you know they're just they're excited
that they're doing porn so they get kind
of a
cocky attitude but
that that doesn't matter you know like
at the end of the day like
they're your co-workers some of them you
get along with and some of them you
don't
but the majority of the time you get
along with them so you seem pretty happy
i am i am pretty happy it's um
porn quite literally like saved my life
from from where i was to where i am now
like mentally
emotionally and like even like
health-wise physically
like i'm a much better-off person and
i don't think i could have done that
without like
the openness that porn gives me
yeah you might your personality might be
perfectly suited to this career because
yeah i think i think it would chew up
and spit out a lot of people right
yeah um you see it happen too like when
i
even when i first started like that's
one of the things that like my agency
told me about they were like you know
you before you dive into this be 100
certain that you can handle certain
things like you can just
you know like your naked bodies
everywhere online people are going to
judge it they're going to talk to you
about it
and you have like a like you know a
scarlet a on your chest for the rest of
your life like oh
they did porn and some people can't
handle that some people
feel very guilty for it and
they end up leaving the industry very
early on because they realize it's not
what they wanted
and so i made certain that that is what
i wanted to do before i went into it you
know i researched it for a long time
before doing it
so yeah definitely it's the right place
for me
but i've seen and know of
people that it's not the right place for
it are you making good money
i am yeah um it's
it's good it's good money and uh
it's it's
sometimes it can be nerve-wracking
because like it's not consistent you
know you're a model like
you don't have a set schedule you you
work
when like people hire you to work it's
random
but it's like you don't have to
work like you know a nine to five
for five days a week to like
get like a decent paycheck you know you
you're literally freelance
yeah it comes when it comes and you keep
it you save it
otherwise you're you're not working yeah
it's just like
most artists is freelance is how they
work well
pretty much everybody in the in the
working world
yeah is being exploited or used you know
whether you work at a
at a department store or a bank or
anything you're you're
you're doing things for money yes and
you're certainly doing things for money
yes do you ever feel like you're
being disrespected or exploited or
anything like that
um i mean especially with your situation
where you're giving you know
much more than just your time yeah you
dedicate your
entire being into porn like
you know that's your body out there that
you're using
for your job i think there's a little
more
i i mean maybe i'm maybe i'm off base
here tell me if i am
but with what you do it's a little more
of your soul is being given than
somebody who works at a grocery store
yeah you know you're putting yourself
into all these situations
and you know you're you're sharing such
an
intimate aspect of yourself with people
that you're just meeting for the first
time or you know
you're never going to see them again or
if you do see them again like
you know they've also had sex with like
20 other people within that span of a
time so it's like
you you
i don't feel used you know i don't i
don't feel like
i'm being exploited or disrespected in
any way
because you know it is a like i'm
consenting to everything that's
happening like i
it's the first thing you do when you
walk in the door is you fill out
these forms you know you talk about hey
am i consenting to this yes i'm
consenting to this did anyone make me do
this no no one made me do this you know
you
and you talk about your do's and don'ts
and what you like what you don't like
all that kind of stuff beforehand and uh
so the only way to me that you could
feel disrespected or exploited in this
industry is if
you personally secretly deep down don't
like what you're doing
you know so the only way to feel
disrespected to me
is if you
put yourself in a situation you didn't
know you didn't want to be in
but you can if you you know don't make
your own informed
decision on things what's
what are some of the strange things
you're required to do it
in this um one time i had to get throat
[ __ ]
like repeatedly until i puked and i had
to puke into a bowl
a dog bowl that said horror on it and
then at the end of it they dumped the
puke on my head and then
the dude pissed it off of me
how do you feel driving home from work
that day
dirty like i was like that was the
dirtiest [ __ ] i've ever done
i mean that doesn't doesn't this impact
you some way subconsciously
no like it wouldn't be i mean
like i just really wanted to take a
bubble bath afterwards like i was like
okay that was intense
because it was like it was an intense
scene like you know i got like slapped
around and yelled at
and degraded and all that kind of stuff
and then i got peed on and like i had my
puke all over me
and i got pink eye the next day because
i don't watch porn so i don't know
what's going on in the industry but i've
heard some stories like what you just
described
yeah is it getting more demented and
more
you know more more extreme like that
more extreme i think so
i think because there's so much porn out
there
like there is so much porn and there's
so many people that do porn now
especially with like only fans
and all these uh clip sites that like
anybody can just upload porn
you know you don't have to have a dvd or
whatever or vhs like you can
use your phone to do it so you have to
do
weird extreme stuff to get noticed by
anyone
do you feel like you know porn
and things like that all kinds of sex
work
um kind of undermines the moral threat
of society
like i mean there's so many different
ways of looking at this but a lot of
people would say that this is all bad
for society
it's bad for mankind that everyone's
i think that i don't necessarily think
it's bad for mankind i can understand
that like
you know the media you consume has an
impact on your life
and who you are and how you act
but it doesn't have to you know like
that's where like
you know self-control comes in like if
you
porn is very satirized like you see it
everywhere like i can't open up my phone
without seeing like
a naked girl on twitter or instagram or
something
and like it's so normal to see that
stuff
all the time and i think that's changed
the way people
view like themselves and like
relationships with people and stuff
but it doesn't have to you know like you
can
not look at that stuff or you can
realize that like the things in porn are
just
fantasy and these are professionals
acting these scenarios out like
you don't have to take it to your core
like
this is what the media wants you to do
or this is what the media wants you to
look like
like no that's just what the media is
producing because
it can you know so i think it takes a
little bit of personal responsibility
within yourself before you can like
blame porn
on yeah but you're being pushed to do
more and more extreme things
i am i am always being pushed to do more
and more extreme things
but i like it like that's what i do i'm
like
i love bdsm and kink and fetish so maybe
again you might be perfectly suited to
this career yeah like i'm suited for the
career like if you're not someone who
likes those things then like
you shouldn't do porn or you can do porn
if you just did you know very specific
what you want to do but yeah like i'm
always trying new things and
there's always a
something else like you go to set and
you're like wow this was the weirdest
craziest [ __ ] i've ever done and then
you go to another set and you're like oh
no this is the weirdest craziest [ __ ]
i've ever done like it's always
something new
like i don't know it's cool
do you ever feel like you're selling
something of yourself that
that you that you question later whether
it's right
um sometimes you know
you have to like i i don't think i'm
selling things that like aren't right to
myself you know if there's a role that
like i don't want to do then i won't do
it you know i'll be like
thanks for the offer but no i'm not
comfortable with that
but um
there are times where it's like i'm like
oh gosh
like this character is totally not how
my personality is like yeah that's just
acting
yeah it's just acting so i get a little
nervous that people are like oh they're
gonna think i'm some like
sweet like innocent bimbo little girl
and it's like
that's totally not who i am so it's like
sometimes you feel like people don't see
your true self
but that's that's about it for like
selling yourself it's just acting though
yeah it's just acting and and your
romantic life your personal life is it
affected by this or do you have one i
no i don't have a romantic life at all
i think a lot of people in the industry
have told me the same thing really
yeah it's just it's hard it's hard it's
hard to balance
um because you know people
hear like oh you do porn well then that
means
it's okay if we hook up all the time
because it's just casual for you and i'm
like actually
i care a lot about my sexual health
because i do porn
and i don't want to hook up with people
all the time and
especially like people that aren't okay
with being tested or using condoms or
anything
and
i think that puts like a little bit of a
damper on my romantic life because i'm
not willing to just like
sleep with anyone and then also uh
it's like you know no one wants to date
someone who has to have sex with other
people all the time
so then like that's also a thing but i
don't really care about it because
you know you're you're only one you're
only young once so i'm like might as
well
you know make money doing what i can
while i can
and worry about the romantic [ __ ] later
you might be one of the few that's
really cut out for this line of work
yeah yeah i i think i'm cut out for it i
know a lot of girls who
like really truly are cut out for it
like
they're passionate about what they're
doing and you can tell like in the
videos like
whether someone enjoys it or whether
they're just doing it for a paycheck and
i hope people see in my content that i
enjoy what i'm doing
you know like i'm not i'm not pretending
to like what's happening you know i do
everything i do because i enjoy doing it
and i think that's like one of the
things that's like really important to
me
with being in porn is like just do what
you want to do like
don't do anything you don't want to do
because you don't have to you know
and what what's that the most important
lesson you've learned you think you're
so young but
what have you learned since you've been
doing this
that like this is gonna sound so cheesy
but it's literally like it
life is what you make it like your life
is how you make your life
like i know not everyone has the
privilege to just
go and make money being hot
but like
it wasn't an easy journey but one day i
woke up and i decided hey i want to be a
model
i want to do porn and i did it and i
noticed that like sometimes
if i am on set and i'm not feeling
myself
you know i'm not i'm not happy i'm not
like
thinking i look good or whatever like
insecurities and all that
then the scene is bad you know like you
can see it on my face
but then if i show up and i'm like i
keep a positive attitude i feel like i
look good i just you know
get yourself in that mindset then i make
a good scene
and like doing that over and over again
made me realize like
anything that i'm doing in my life is
exactly how i make it like
i can make it good or i can make it bad
and so i just and i think porn made me
realize for the first
time in my life that i am my own success
or i am my own misery you know so
i finally figured out that i can take
responsibility for
what i do and how i feel about it that's
great that's what it does
you're becoming a wise sage as you do
porn
yes i'm all wise and
you know mentally i'm like an 80 year
old man sipping tea
in his little cottage yeah
yeah just like chilling all sexy but
like
like i'm like i got i do
i don't know i just i got this like
older mentality i feel like since i
started porn like it just
you learn so much about yourself in such
a small amount of time
you're certainly taking an alternative
path to maturity
yeah yeah i took um instead of you know
like slowly climbing up the ladder i
just like
took an escalator like i was like we're
gonna do it
like if i'm gonna figure my life out i'm
going to figure it out now and i'm going
to do it in the most extreme way
possible
yes you did you chose that path all
right
well thank you so much for coming in
again yeah no thank you for having me
again and i wish you the best of luck
i wish you the best of luck thank you